We saw in the previous video that things started
Already looks bad
In October 1789 we saw the march of women where
Doubts began to grow that the royal authority was
The grain is stored
So they went to Versailles and Aspen
In Persia they forced the royal family, and forced Louis XVI
Marie Antoinette to be back in Paris
Then things went on in the heat.
Many revolutions began
The king did not know what to do.
Of course he did not like the situation
People's doubts grew in the king
The nobles began to leave the country, they were emigrating
Outside France.
But the King and the Queen have become suspicious that
- What if the people have more radical ideas (extreme tendency towards radical change)
About that constitutional monarchy?
Maybe we should also run away
And so we saw in 1791 - and let me write all this on me
Timetable.
We are now in the year 1791
This is a review of the previous video
In June, we saw the royal family try to escape
The royal family is trying to escape
But were arrested in "Varnier" and returned
To Paris to stay under
House arrest in "Toliere"
This building is here
No longer exists
But if I went to Paris and visited the Louvre, I would
You find that the Louvre has a gate open to a shell
"Toliere Garden"
This is the location of the building's site in the past
The royal family ended up under house arrest in the "
This was in June.
Then in July 1791, again a review of
Previous video
People said: Hey, they tried to escape and this is equal
To abdicate
They do not even want to be our property and our property and we do not
We need kings and queens from the ground up
Thus began the most radical elements, the most radical and leftist elements
And especially the "Yacoubi" group began in
Preparation of petitions in "Champ de Mars" is mainly to make people say
We do not need the property anymore.
We need the republic only.
We need a state without kings and queens.
But then the National Assembly sent some armies.
Conditions worsened.
I threw stones and shot and 50 people died.
This is what happened in what is known as the Champ de Mars massacre.
This is the time of the massacre of the Champ de Mars.
So things really started to get worse and the situation got worse.
And so we get to the end of 1791 but to make things turn
Worse yet, we have not yet reached the real end.
In August, it was the announcement of the "Belentiz" which
As we have seen, the rulers of Austria and Prussia say
They do not like what happens to
The ruling class in France.
And for obvious reasons.
Well, first Leopold II was Marie Antoinette's brother.
But deeper, they did not like the idea that
People revolt against the ruling / royal class.
It is possible to give this ideas to the peoples the situation is repeated in
Their empires and their country.
Therefore, although the situation has not been taken seriously yet
These young people have made this declaration.
This made people in France more skeptical.
And now, while all this was happening, you may have remembered
"The right of the tennis court" was signed
Several years ago.
Where they said we are preparing a constitution.
Thus a constitution has already been drafted.
Thus in 1791, the National Assembly or Assembly
Legislative provisions of the 1971 Constitution
Established for France as a constitutional monarchy
And so they said: Well, we will continue to rule a king.
But it will only be a symbolic form.
And not necessarily a person who can make laws.
The National Assembly will be responsible for this.
The MEC will have few powers to challenge legislation
And so on.
But most of his powers will be removed.
This was the constitutional monarchy.
Constitutional Monarchy
Is really on the same line as what was already happening
In Britain.
But at some levels this is a great achievement.
They had this oath "oath" to put the Constitution.
But on another level, things were getting worse
In France and in Paris in particular.
The revolution was completely focused on what was happening
In Paris and Versailles.
The situation was so bad that it looked like it was
Side view.
To a certain extent revolutionaries have gone
Beyond the desire for constitutional monarchy only.
They began to think they needed a republic.
We saw this during the massacre of the Champ de Mars,
People have already started to sign me
Establishment of a Republic.
Then he started shooting at them, which probably drove them more to desire
In a republican system.
You may remember something else from the video
First, the thing that hastened
The revolution is complete.
Or at least in my opinion, one of the most important reasons
In fueling the revolution is
That France was bankrupt.
And people were hungry.
I keep this situation all the time where it was all
Politicians, revolutionaries and monarchists
They move and try somehow
Develop a strategy to strengthen their position.
No one has solved any of these
Problems all this time ..
There is no money in France.
There is famine, people are hungry.
And so we will find almost everyone, whether you look at Louis XVI
And let me look at him again, it's nice to remember how he was
sound.
Whether you are talking about Louis XVI and who is now under
Mortgages are house arrest, or you are talking about a lot of
The revolutionaries, everyone began to say: God damn how we can
To solve that problem?
People will send us out if we do not solve
The problem of hunger and bankruptcy.
As you will see through history more than once, the best solution
For this, or what he thinks is the best solution
Is the declaration of war.
And so they declared war on Austria.
If we look at the subject from the point of view of Louis XVI, we find it
Think about it as a winner anyway.
If the war succeeds after he has put his weight on
This war.
And this happened - let me write the dates.
This always helps me to frame what happened.
This was near the end of 1791, and the war was declared
In April this was in 1792.
Order was here in April.
And if we think about the subject at least from a point of view
Louis XVI We already found a successful project.
If they win the war, this will make him loved
More and perhaps more powerful.
They may have plundered the country's wealth
To help build the cupboard of France.
If the situation worsens in the war and France is defeated, what?
Will happen?
Then Austria and often peoples
Which fights against you
We will soon realize that France will fight with
Most strong European.
But if the war is lost, it is those who rule
Kings will be rid of
The revolutionaries may be Louis XVI's return to power.
So it is a good idea from Louis XVI's point of view.
For many revolutionaries, they wanted
To solve these problems. So they said: Yes, it will be
A good chance if we could plunder another country.
If we can steal again from other countries to become
France at least less hungry.
And perhaps we can also spread the revolution.
We can get rid of all other kings.
This will not be just a French revolution
A complete European revolution.
Thus the war was declared against Austria.
Very quickly, they tried to attack Austria
And Holland which were somehow part
From Austria.
And so they attacked here the Austrian Hollandi.
But they sort of fell into a quagmire there.
The attack was not as successful as they expected it to be.
And Prussia which as you remember was involved
In the "Belenitz Declaration" decided to participate in
War alongside Austria.
Thus, Russia attacked an initial attack
Very successful.
And was able to move towards France
Then the general in charge of the Prussian army, Duke
Brunswick announced the Brunswick statement
Let me write this
Statement by Brunswick
Which basically corresponds to the Billents statement
But his successor is a bigger force now
Because this man, Duke Brunswick in fact
He has an army invading France
He declares his statement, which he says he intends
To get rid of this revolutionary government
It installs the power of the machine again
Prove the king
All this happened in April 1792
The war against Austria was a successful decision in all cases for the king
The rebels wanted to spread the revolution
And looting of other countries
Then, immediately in Russia, they began attacking France
And says it will restore the king's authority
You can imagine now that this happened to the rebels
He made them more suspicious of the King's intentions
I thought that the king held a kind of secret agreement with
Prussian, or with other enemies are
They stand against them. Thus in August 1792, the
Within a few months, 5 or 6 months later
In August 1792, you basically had
Municipality of Paris
When I say the municipality of Paris, in fact it is
Government of Paris at this time
It was also controlled by radical revolutionaries
Mostly "Jacobites"
They broke into the royal residence
Eultoleris
This painting here is conceived
The rebels, mostly Jacobites, who really
They broke into the tolieres
They imprisoned Louis XVI and Marie Antoinette
Because they thought, Well Belarus has an army
Announced its intention to help the King regain his authority
We will jail the king because we do not know
What he intends!
They were imprisoned at King Louis XVI
And Marie Antoinette
They also managed some intrigues inside
National Assembly
There is actually a kefal session of the association
Nationalism, which means that a lot of
The opponents were not there
Accordingly, there was a meeting of the leftists,
Radicals, and Jacobites.
Thus in August and at the Kefal meeting, the Assembly announced
For the Republic
As if declaring that Louis XVI
No longer a king.
This is the nation or the state that we have now
Not governed by and will not be ruled by a king
It's now a republic
It is a government without a king
And while all this was happening, we have these
Gangs roam around the area around Paris
They try and kill people who appear
They are skeptical, or they are allied with
Nobles or kings, or appear to have signs of royal support
Or even want to return the property!
In the midst of these riots and arbitrary executions
The gangs killed at least 1,400 people
1400 were executed at this time
As you can see, the situation has become even uglier
And in more and more stalemate
The king is imprisoned
And you will see it will not take
Long prison
But the end will not be good for him
Basically, the rebels have said
That France is now a republic
All this has been done and the state is at war with two superpowers, with
Austria and Prussia
And now they can stop, and when they say
I'm talking about the French army
Eventually they are able to repel
Invasion of the Prussian army
And this situation they call the Valmy predicament, it is not clear who won!
The Prussians were not eager to enter France
So the Prussians did not press much for sending more armies
Therefore - at least - temporarily external threat
Disintegration, if we want to half the status quo
The National Assembly went ahead and announced that they were
Get rid of - I mean, they already declared the republic
But they are more extinct
If we are now in September 1792
We have a truce in Valme
Download Download
And then the National Assembly or
National Conference, they decided they would write
A new constitution
Thus the Constitution proclaimed in 1791 is no longer recognized
It lasted only for a year.
Now a new constitution
The intention is to write a new constitution
Now, during all this, all the wasted blood
After the imprisonment of Louis XVI, and the riots
Throughout Paris, arbitrary killing, this only
Foreshadowing many unfortunate events that will occur in the future
But in the coming year
By 1793 - let me write this in red
If we are now in 1739
And the National Assembly, the first thing they did was, or
Maybe I should be more precise
In January 1793, they remembered they had already been put
King, put him in prison, they are in war
With countries that have declared their goal
In the restoration of the King's power
The first thing they did was to execute King Louis XVI
This is the picture of execution
He was executed with a guillotine
And here's the guillotine doctor
It was actually chosen, here it is
Guillotine, has been invented to be used
In the execution of people in a humane manner
At that time, when people are killed, it is not the goal
They felt pain, only the aim was to execute them.
So we will use this so-called human machine
Guillotine
Which we use a very square blade to cut
Someone's head
It was invented by this doctor who stands here
But the first to try it out of the VIPs
Louis XVI, was executed by Guillotine in January
And from February, remember that people are still hungry
They are still eager to spread the revolution, they are still
They want to plunder the rest of the countries
Thus in February, the National Assembly, or the Council
National, Government of Revolution, declared war on
Britain and the Republic of the Netherlands
-
You do not know from this, I will
Tell you later
And the Netherlands
Perhaps now you are wondering, how is this France
One state here, you will be able to wage war on
Austria and Prussia?
Now the war is being declared against the Dutch and Great Britain
The previous month Asania and Portugal also did
Declaring war and allied with
Austria and Prussia
So how this country only, France, how to these
The revolutionary government has to support itself in the face of armies
Of many nations?
The answer to this question is that the revolutionary government
Announced in February what they called collective duds
I'm not French and I seem to say it wrong I'm sure.
Collective dams
It is basically the first version of what we know now
The name of the draft
They were able to impose the following
Every young Frenchman has not married and is well
He will be a conscript in the army
And thus were able to immediately raise
The numbers of recruits for hundreds of thousands
Within two years he was
The number of recruits, according to several documented sources, amounted to one million
Or more of the soldiers
This is different from what you are doing
Kingdoms to develop the numbers of their armies
They pay salaries to professional recruits
Thus these kingdoms were small armies compared
In France and the revolutionary government in the collection of soldiers
The government said, Well this is a government of the people
It is the people
So now you are not fighting for a king, you
You fight for yourselves
You are fighting for your representation, so no
You return to the control of foreign kings
Thus all the French joined the army of their state
Thus France now has the largest army in Europe
But I repeat that all this happens within a framework
Riots and instability throughout France
There are the kings who are fighting
The revolutionaries
People are still hungry
As a kind of tightening I think, in April
1792 National Assembly established a committee
Public Security, which looks like a very nice commission
Committee on Public Security
This committee has become the virtual government, or
We can tell the de facto government
She was under the management of this good-looking man
This is here, Maximilian Robesbury
He looks like a civilized man
Maximilian Robesbury
But in fact, what the General Security Committee was going through was uncertainty
Great suspicion and uncertainty
Especially under the administration of Maximilian Robesbury
Which was very suspicious of all
Just doubt that someone is not radical enough
Or someone who did not like him, or someone
May help bring him down from the administration of the committee - give orders
To be executed with a guillotine
This was actually the beginning of the period of terror
The era of terrorism
Almost over the next year, on different orders, what to do
16,000 men were executed with guillotine
They were killed by Dr. Glutani's invention
These are just estimates of murder
There is no documentation for this
But it is believed that nearly 40,000 were done
Execution
This essentially means that their job is: You are guilty of this, and we know you are
Guilty, yes, you soldier, kill him!
-
So these times were really bloody times.
Imagine that all this was happening in
Paris and its suburbs
And suddenly in one basic city
There are tens of thousands of people
Slaughtered, only if this man - Maximilian - or from
Working with him or even those who work with them
I think you are not revolutionary enough
Or your allegiance to the revolution is unconvincing
Now in the end people doubt the
Maximilian Robesbury
They began to believe that all this uncertainty would hurt the revolution
More than to help her
And then in a thermodynamic reflex - it seems to be so
Type of refrigerator or heater
Thermodynamic reaction
Now this is here, this in July 1794
This is called a thermodynamic apostasy, and I am
I may record a full video about it, because
The revolutionary government is a fact
A new calendar has been created
Where one month was renamed Thermidor, which was
Which was basically July was moved a bit
As well as changing the number of hours per day
They had 10 hours a day, 100 minutes an hour
100 seconds per minute
They have a week of 10 days each month
Yes it's a full calendar
But Thermidor was July
The fact was the July Revolution, when people
They were overwhelmed by Maximilian's actions
If in 1794 July 1794 is also
- you do it back on you -
Here, in July 1794
Here's this good-looking guy
He was executed with a guillotine.
Now there are two things I would like to point out
I'll go back a little to 1793
Perhaps as a kind of observation
We saw that in January Louis XVI was executed
And the opinion is back to you whether it is
The decision to execute him well or bad
Marie Antoinette was also executed in October.
Marie Antoinette
She was also executed, and this was in 1793
9 months after the execution of her husband
And as a small note in this paragraph as
You can imagine that all regions of France were unstable and unstable
Then in 1793 there was a rebellion.
This was in July 1793.
So it is a year before the end of the reign of terror, really
During the "era of terrorism"
And in the port of Toulon there was a rebellion against
The government is revolutionary.
They were thwarted with help
Captain Artillery
The artillery captain is the person in charge
Attack using guns
And this artillery captain who helped suppress
Rebellion, attributed to him, I think
In the revolutionary government - I need to write it down
Somewhere in preparation
For the next duo - if in July 1739 in Toulon
The new artillery captain seemed to know
what's he doing
His name was Napoleon Bonaparte
And we will talk about it a lot in the next video.